y listo
tras meses de espera las fronteras
estadounidenses abrirán para los
viajeros que tengan la pauta completa de
vacunación por lo que los negociantes de
la ciudad el paso hacen los últimos
preparativos para recibir al fin a sus
clientes mexicanos
la pandemia tocó a todo el mundo súsper
en cualquier tipo y sólo estamos
esperando que la gente venga a
visitarnos también
va a ayudar a las empresas ya la
economía en el paso y juárez
[Música]
el regreso de los turistas es un alivio
para los comerciantes que se vieron
enfrentados a la incertidumbre generada
por las restricciones impuestas durante
la pandemia y poder no sólo si abrimos
lo creeré w bat pero ahora mismo
realmente no lo sé porque todos los
meses dicen lo mismo y sé que el próximo
mes que el próximo mes eso casi durante
dos años o mosto y el heno en tijuana
también esperan el 8 de noviembre con
optimismo muchos migrantes quieren ver
revivir su deseo de acceder al
territorio estadounidense e intentarlo
de que abra la frontera horita y luego
poder ir allá estamos vacunados ya
tenemos la prueba de cody tenemos todo
listo verdad y posiblemente creo que ya
no debería haber ninguna excusa sin
embargo el gobierno joe biden no ha
anunciado un cambio en la política
migratoria
pensando que el hecho de que reabran la
frontera para las comunidades que puedan
entrar de forma regular pues también
ellos tienen una esperanza de que quizás
pueda ser también la ayuda a las
comunidades que están buscando el asilo
o la ayuda humanitaria de los eeuu hay
esa desinformación antes de la pandemia
casi un millón de personas cruzaban cada
día por la frontera muchos lo hacían
para trabajar o estudiar ahora a pesar
de la apertura varios siguen en el limbo
al no poder acceder a las vacunas
aprobadas por eeuu